a lot of seven adventists believe that wearing
jewelry example earrings chains are not a sin
and that they can wear them some also believe
that body tattoos are not sin what does god say
all right i knew trouble was coming soon
let's pray father give us a heart to receive
biblical truth and not social customs in
jesus name i pray amen go to genesis 3.
we read verse six and verse seven well
let's read from one to seven read the bible
genesis three one to seven we're
talking about ornaments and decorations
on the outside all that stuff we call jewelry
which is such a big business do you have it
now the serpent was more subtle than any
beast of the field which the lord god had made
and he said unto the woman yea hath god said
he shall not eat of every tree of the garden
and the woman said unto the serpent we may
eat of the fruit of the trees of the garden
but of the fruit of the tree which is
in the midst of the garden god hath said
he shall not eat of it neither shall he touch it
lest ye die and the serpent said unto the woman ye
shall not surely die for god doth know that in the
day ye eat thereof then your eyes shall be opened
and ye shall be as god's knowing good and evil
verse six and when the woman saw that the tree was
good for food which it was not by the way and that
was pleasant to the eyes and a tree to be desired
to make one wise she took of the fruit thereof and
did eat and gave also unto her husband with her
and he did it now verse 8 and the eyes of them
both were up verse 7 and they knew that they
were naked and they sewed fig leaves together and
made themselves aprons what was made in verse 7
what what was made be specific aprons of leaves
let's go to verse 21. read for me unto adam also
and to his wife did the lord god make coats of
skins and clothe them okay i want to draw some
of your attention what was made on the first
day too slow too slow too slow live second day
for a moment third day
is this an adventist church fourth day sun moon
and stars fifth day birds and fish sixth day land
animals and human beings question for you what did
adam and eve make in that week of creation nothing
nothing all the making the creating
was done by god go back to genesis 3 7.
we're looking at a principle a negative principle
read verse 7 again and the eyes of them both
were opened and they knew that they were
naked stop read verse 25 of chapter 2. they
were both naked the man and his wife and were not
ashamed are you with me but that was before sin
after sin they're ashamed so what are
they trying to deal with the embarrassment
the shame the guilt that's what they're trying to
handle how did they handle it they made airprints
of leaves now that's the first thing the bible
records a human being ever made on the earth
something to cover where the outside are you
not listening to me something to beautify
the outside something to help me feel a
little better about myself are you with me
with this principle in mind
now let's go to zechariah 3
zechariah 3
are you there not yet come on come
on find zechariah find malachi
then work your way back
malachi okay you got it now
you sure i said zechariah you have zechariah
chapter 3 what's the first word in there he
showed me joshua the high priest come on standing
before the angel of the lord and satan standing at
his right hand to resist him keep reading and he
unto satan the lord rebuked thee o satan even the
lord that have chosen jerusalem rebuke thee is not
this a brand plucked out of the fire verse three
now joshua was clothed with filthy garments
stop describe the leaves safety garments
because god had to remove them are you following
me 50 garments now joshua's clothed with filthy
garments and stood before the angel keep reading
and he answered and speaking to those that stood
before him saying what take away the filthy
garments from him and to him he said behold
i have caused that iniquity to pass from thee
and i will clothe thee with change of raymond now
in joshua we have a symbol of how god functions he
removes that man-made stuff and replaces it with
the symbol of the righteousness of his son argue
with me now let's go back to genesis genesis 3
21 keep the information from zechariah 3 verse 1
to four let's go to genesis 3 verse 21 unto adam
also and to his wife did the lord god make coats
of skins and clothe them before he put the skins
on what did he have to remove those aprons of
leaves man-made for the purpose of feeling better
reducing a sense of guilt and shame now to see how
worthless the aprons were let's go to verse 8 of
genesis 3 and they heard the voice of the lord
god walking in the garden in the cool of the day
and adam and his wife hid themselves from the
presence of the lord god amongst the trees of the
garden now why are they hiding if they already
covered because there's no human covering that
can improve your appearance in the sight of god
are you following me no you're not following me
verse 21 coats of skin the blood of christ is
what needs to cover us now having said all of that
let us go to exodus exodus no genesis 35 it's
10 after seven when does the sun set it what
temperance and all things temperance
temperance okay we're going to genesis
35 we're even first one let me pray father as
we continue please lord teach us we want to
know because salvation is knowledge teach us
their god in the name of jesus christ i pray
amen now let me set this up for you in chapter
34 simeon and levi kill all the men in the city
because the prince of that city had
raped their sister jacob had 13 children
12 boys and one girl you know that girl who can
be protected when she was raped simeon and levi
went to the city and said to the prince look
you defiled our sister you have to marry her the
prince said yeah i'll marry you but the boy said
you can't marry her because you're uncircumcised
the person said we'll get circumcised simon levi
the servants came in circumcised all the men
waited three days for them to be
properly immobile are you following me
then came with the swords and killed all the men
brought the women into captivity and the children
all the possessions of the city and in the field
and took it all away and when this terrible
thing happened jacob said the surrounding
tribes will kill me because i'm just a small
group now god is going to get them out of this
are you following me he's getting them out of
this crisis that's what we're about to read
verse 1 genesis 35 and god said unto jacob arise
go up bethel and dwell there and make there an
altar unto god that appeared unto thee when thou
fled is from the face of esau thy brother remember
jacob running from esau okay verse two then jacob
said unto his household and to all that with him
put away the strange gods that are among
you and be clean and change your garments
this is a spiritual change you've offended god
changes have to be made put away of strange gods
be clean change your garments now verse three what
does that say and let us arise and go up to bethel
and i will make the an altar unto god that what
answered me in the day of my distress and which
was with me in the way which i went now jacob
said in verse two put away the strange gods
be clean change your garments verse four
read with me now and they gave unto jacob
all the strange gods which were in their hands
and all the earrings which were in their ears and
jacob hid them under the oak which was by shechem
now all the jewelry jacob took and buried it
go to matthew 25. matthew
25 we'll read from verse 14
are you with me you have matthew 25 verse 14.
okay you say yes but you're still turning pages
all right okay okay are we there now can i rely on
that yes okay read with me for the kingdom of is
as a man traveling into a far country who called
his own servants and delivered unto them his goods
next verse and after one he gave five talents
to another two and to another one to every man
according to his several abilities and straight
away took his journey now next verse 16 i think
it is now he that had received the five talents
went and traded with the same and made them other
five talents likewise he that had received
two he also gained other two read verse 18
went and digged in the earth and hid his lord's
money what did jacob do with the jewelry in the
earth what does this man matter with a talent
signifying what how did the fellow with five
get ten what did he do yes he traded he used
it are you with me are you following he used it
went from five to ten what about the fellow who
went from two to four he used it he put it to use
the fella with one what did he
do he buried it meaning what
he didn't use it what did jacob do with that
jewelry he buried it it was not to be used
go to exodus 33. exodus 33 we have another
crisis and the israelites are full of crises
we have another crisis these people have just
worshipped the golden calf and god was this
close to wiping them out moses sent the levites
with their swords 3 000 were killed in that
day now god wants them to do something to
show repentance and a change of mind and heart
verse 1 exodus 33 let me know when you're there
read with me and the lord said unto moses depart
and go up hands thou on the people which thou
has brought up out of the land of egypt unto
the land which i swear unto abraham to
isaac and to jacob saying unto thy seed
will i give it keep reading and i will send
my angel before thee and i will drive out
the canaanite the amorite and the hittite then
the parasite the hivite and the jebusite now
verse three unto a land flowing with milk and
honeycomb everything for i will not go up in the
midst of thee for ye are without naked people lest
i consume you in the way god is saying i am so mad
i don't want to travel with you in your
condition because i'll just destroy you
is god love can god get mad is his madness just
yes verse four and when the people heard these
evil tidings come on they mourned and no man did
put on him he they to put on all jewelry they had
verse five read it for the lord had said unto
moses say unto the children of israel ye are
a stiff naked people i will come up in the
midst of thee in a moment and consume thee
therefore now put off thy ornaments from there
that i may know what to do unto thee verse 6
and the children of israel stripped themselves
of the ornaments by the mount horeb now
let me tell you the hebrew rendering
strip themselves by the mount means from the mount
or meaning from that point on they left them off
from mount horeb they left them off subsequent
travels we have two spiritual crises and god
says you need to straighten yourself out
on each occasion get rid of all that stuff
now go to ezekiel 28. let's read
from verse 13. this is a description
of lucifer before he fell are you with
me i'm not convinced you are but okay
ezekiel 28 reading from verse 13 are you there
okay some are you still looking for ezekiel
all right i'll give you 10
seconds to find ezekiel it's 7 18.
you have ezekiel 28 18 13 read with me
thou has been in eden the garden of god
every precious stone was thy covering come on the
sardius the topaz the diamond what else the barrel
onyx the jasper what else the sapphire
the emerald the carbuncle and gold
keep reading the workmanship of thy
tabernacle of thy pies was prepared in thee
in the day that that was created who is that
lucifer he was covered with precious stones
let's find out what his problem was
go to verse 17 and read it for me
come on thine heart was lifted up in the
eye because of thy beauty come on that has
corrupted thy wisdom by reason of thy brightness
stop when lucifer realized how pretty he was
thine heart was lifted up in thee because
of thy beauty you know you went in high
school the most stuck up person was the
girl who thought she was the prettiest
his outward appearance led to his muslims
only reason but it contributed now
when god made lucifer he was covered with all that
stuff when god made adam was this sin in the world
in the universe when god made adam was the sin
in the universe yes who would sin for lucifer
are you with me so did god know the
catastrophe he had with this pretty angel
how did he make adam give me one word starts
with n naked what did he have on him nothing
what did eve have on her nothing now does god want
us to breathe what did he give us we're two holes
are you with me ah you're not listening does he
want us to listen what did he give us with holes
if he wanted us to wear earrings you
got to put another hole right here
and one right here uh you don't like me anymore
are you listening to me yeah he made
harmony with nothing on them a baby
comes out of the womb and two days later
you pound a hole in the air and you pound
and you drive a screwdriver through something
and you cuff some with a saw to hide metal
let me tell you some of jewelry in ancient times
people wore them to identify with their idols
some jewelry formed were called amulets and amulet
was devised to protect you from evil spirits
some jewelry had markings on
them that represented the idols
and as the idols were decorated people decorate
themselves so they look like come on they're idles
go to leviticus 19.
leviticus 19.
well i forgot to welcome those listening
online wherever you are god bless you
and may the truth of his word reach you unopposed
what book did i say leviticus what chapter 19
read verse 28 microscopically are you there
and keep in mind the key word that describes
or summarizes leviticus is holiness read verse
28 now you shall make no cuttings in your flesh
for the dead or print marks upon you i am now
don't cut yourself don't print marks on you
that's what people did to identify with the
dead and their ancestors whom they worship are
you following me remember the prophets of baal on
mount carmel with elijah when baal wouldn't answer
what does this have to do cut them all don't do
that now when god says don't cut yourself what
does he mean don't cut yourself don't tell god
it's a little cute pastor they don't like what
i'm saying don't tell god but it's just a little
cut because adam could have said it's just a grape
that's all i consumed why are you
putting me out god said don't do it
now to have earrings in your
ear do you have to pierce it
or some do you up here is that a cut why are you
hesitating as dory why stammer is that a cut yes
don't make me mad
the verse says don't print any marks on your body
are your toes a part of your body come on tell
me you don't sound sure huh why are they red
that's a mark now someone is
saying this guy is extreme
i'm not extreme
you either for god or you're not now let me say
this some people are convicted at different times
different time i was preaching somewhere and i
made a call to give up all that jewelry people
came and put rings and it on the table and
i told them head elder the pastor sell it
and give the money to the doctor society
they took it off and put it there mm-hmm
go to first timothy chapter two i know
someone watching me wants to kill me but
the pastor is here to protect me he won't let
me get killed you want to kill me i know that
i feel that heat coming from you first
timothy chapter two let's read from verse nine
i'll miss you when i'm gone i really will god
bless you all the days of your life god bless
you god bless you i mean it first peter first
timothy chapter two do you have that let me
pray father as we continue teach us god we forget
quickly teach us and soften that stony heart that
does not like what is being said in jesus name
i pray amen first timothy 2 verse 9 says what
in like manner also that women adorn
themselves with modest power in modest
apparel with shame-facedness and sobriety let
me tell you something modesty is almost extinct
when i was a boy you know what
a modest person looks like
modesty today is almost extinct people
in the church no longer understand
what modesty is i was coming through
johannesburg south africa and uh oh
and i saw a lady dressed and the moment i
saw her i was impressed with the modesty
wishes i wanted to go and tell her but as a
preacher you can't just do these things but
he must understand you but i said lord bless
that woman you can tell she respected herself
and she was not advertising for a
man are you following me she was just
dressed modestly covered and i i looked at
her i admired i said god bless that woman
modesty means very little in the church today
are you with me because our standards are not
biblical or ellen white they are the world
finish verse 9 of first timothy 2 again what
does that say in like manner also that women adorn
themselves in modest power with shamefacedness
and in other words you ought to be ashamed if
you walk out of the house looking like that
come on not with or gold or pearls or costly array
now there's controversy as to what brought it here
means that i have no position on it but what
we do know there are some hairstyles the bible
condemns are you with me now some people were
chatting all right whether or not you understand
what broadened hair means it does tell us
there are some hairstyles that god does not
approve of they do not reflect christian modesty
now you can decide if yours falls under that or
not i'm not here to do that but i'll tell
you that verse condemns certain hair styles
but there's a holy spirit that
convicts you if you're genuine with god
go to first peter chapter three
we read from verse one first
peter three reading from verse one
have you found that no some
people are still looking
all right we'll wait patience is a
virtue we'll wait you have five seconds
you have it now read with me likewise you wise
being subjection to your own husbands if any obey
not the word they also may without the word be won
by the conversation of the wife while they behold
your chaste conversation coupled with fear let
me explain that what peter is telling women who
matter to unconverted men don't like the man let
him see your holy life and that you still respect
him as your husband let him see that and that
will win him don't insist he comes to church he's
an adult don't badger him until he seeks mental
help leave the man alone just be faithful to god
respect him as your husband and that will
do the work all right now they also made
without the word be won by the consciousness
of the while while they behold your chaste
conversation coupled with fear read verse 3 who's
adorning let it not be that outward the dawning of
adding the hair again or or of putting
on of a power meaning very expensive
clothes verse four but let it be the hidden man
of the heart in that which is not corruptable
so we have corruptable in verse four then
what is corruptable what is in verse three
read verse 3 again who's adorning let
it not be that outward the dawning of
uh or wearing of gold or putting off apparel
expensive clothes gold all the weeds whatever
people do that is corruptable meaning it passes
away verse 4 says but let it be the hidden manner
of the heart in that which is not corruptable
even the ornament of a meek and quiet spirit
which in the sight of god is of great price
watson number three is of no value to god
what's the number four is of great value to
god and your child of god your first interest
is what is important to god now read verse
five interesting verse for after this manner
all time the holy women also who
trusted in god adorned themselves stop
that's how the holy women of the old conducted
themselves modestly that's what the bible says
now let me finish on jury with this go
to matthew not matthew revelation 12.
i know the subject is not popular i know that
you're as quiet as a graveyard okay revelation 12.
do you have revelation 12. let's read the
first one read with me and they appeared a
great wonder in heaven a woman clawed to the
sun and the moon under her feet and upon her
head a crown of twelve stars stopped describe
how this woman is adorned how is she described
clothed with the sun what does the sun give light
what were adam and eve surrounded by before they
sinned light keep reading the moon under her feet
what does the moon give light and upon ahead a
crown of twelve stars what do the stars give light
when were they made genesis 1 sun moon and stars
one of their reasons was let them be for signs
for seasons for days and years and let them be
for light in the firmament of the earth to give
light upon the earth she is adorned in the light
go to revelation 17. let's look at another woman
you have revelation 17
let's reverse fourth what does that
say the woman was arrayed in purple
and scarlet color and death with gold precious
stone and pearl what do you understand by date
there's a word the rap world gave
us bling are you following me
watch out now from the rap world gave us bling i
mean the woman in revelation 17 she is bling-bling
it used to be bling-bling then they shorten it
to bling that's what describes her she was dead
i couldn't walk straight so heavy with jewry
now listen to me carefully the one in
12 is adorned in the light of christ
the one in 17 with all the precious tones and
jewelry the one in 12 represents god's through
church the one in 17 the corrupt church you choose
which one you'd like to look like when you dress
i'm not telling you you choose now let's get off
this unpleasant subject what's the next question